but we start with an active homicide
investigation just north of downtown
this is all unfolding near cheyenne and
civic center let's get right out to
sasha loftis for an update on that
investigation
denise and brian this seems to be a
pretty large scene here off of civic
center it's hard to see from this angle
but it appears that most of this complex
is blocked off as police piece together
what happened now officers say this all
happened around six this evening they
were called to these apartments on civic
center near cheyenne after hearing
reports of a shooting they found a man
in his 30's who died on scene we spoke
with the woman who lives near here and
was home when the shooting started
i heard gunshots i went to the window
looked out
it sounded like fireworks then two
minutes later heard sirens so i knew it
was gunshots that's real scary because
we already experienced my house and car
getting shot up as soon as i moved here
so now it's some whole other crime scene
right here
no word yet on a suspect or if any
arrests have been made in this
particular case crime scene
investigators are still working as they
have been for a while and they are set
to be out here for a while longer no
word on any road closures any major road
closures at least here on civic center
but you should expect some delays as
police are blocking blocking that right
shoulder again on civic center just
north of cheyenne reporting live tonight
sasha loftis live local now